- Claude can also do the hosting now.
Like, you can literally just say like, host it, you know?
And then it will go do that.
You know, I did that for the Zero Trust World thing.
- Best part of hacking, when you can just, you know,
critical thing, right?
- Yeah.
- Dude.
- All right, y'all.
We've talked about ThreatLocker ring fencing a lot.
We know how it allows you to set ACLs and policies
for exactly what an application is allowed to do in your network.
But today I'm gonna tell you how it does that, okay?
Three technologies.
Mini filter drivers, window filtering platform,
and EX version, kernel notification routines.
Mini filter drivers are essentially a hook or callback
for IO requests, okay?
So when you're trying to write or read from a file.
You can create a hook with those and approve or deny
based off of the ThreatLocker ACL.
Windows filtering platform, similar situation,
but for connect bind requests, right?
You can say, okay, hey, is this process allowed to talk
to port 443 over there on the internet?
Yes or no?
Approve or deny.
Lastly, you've got EX version kernel notification routines.
The EX version is important because it allows you to approve
or deny versus just getting a notification from the kernel.
And this is specific for hooking various native API calls
like nt create user process, which is what you would use
to like spin up PowerShell.exe or something like that.
Okay?
So those three are very useful to ThreatLocker's
ring fencing core technology.
Hope you enjoyed learning how this is implemented.
Check out ThreatLocker if you think your work could benefit
from something like that.
All right, let's go back to the show.
All right, dude.
So I actually have a confession to make.
Uh-huh.
So you remember, don't uh-huh be like that.
So you remember on the pod a couple of months ago
when I said I'll never give a talk ever again?
Yes.
So I accidentally gave a talk.
You already did it.
I already gave a talk at Zero Trust World.
And it was so much fun, dude.
Oh my gosh, it was great.
And like, obviously ThreatLocker is great.
They sponsor the pod.
They're really instrumental to what we do here on the pod.
But that conference is freaking great, man.
Is it their conference?
It is massive.
Yeah.
And my talk, can I brag on it for just a second?
Yeah, of course.
Like, I was so pleased because I roll up there
and I like, you know, get everything set up.
And then the people start coming in.
And the people start coming in.
And they gave laptops to every participant, too,
at the workshops.
Like, the laptops were sitting in the seats, you know,
that were there for them to use.
You don't take them home.
But like, you know, they prepared for you in advance.
They imaged them and everything.
So anyway, all of the seats fill up.
And then there's still a long line of people.
And then they come up, you know, the ThreatLocker team
comes up and they're like, hey, Justin, sorry to do this to you.
But the line is like around the corner still.
We need to put you in this bigger room.
So like last minute before the talk starts, we moved like 400 people
to this next room, you know, and then that room fills up
and there's people standing in the back.
And the turnout was awesome.
And the crowd was so engaged, man.
They were like doing the labs like a long way.
We had more than half of the people, you know,
raise their hand saying, I finished the lab, you know, which was sick.
What was the lab?
OK, so the lab was and this this is where I'm sorry.
Thank you for bringing me back around there.
This is where all of this comes comes back to,
which was the reason I don't didn't want to do talks
is because I freaking hate prepping slides.
Yeah, you don't want to prep, right.
But just like you said,
all you do is you write an outline in a .md file
and then you just give it to Cloud Code
and it just builds a website
for you with all of your slides on it.
And that is the best for us as hackers,
because not only is like,
are you dealing with HTML rather than like drag this element here?
You know, that sort of thing.
But you also can just build the the labs
in like the interactive workshop directly into the slides.
Oh, that's dope.
It's awesome, dude.
It's freaking awesome.
And it was so fun to present no issues.
You know, you just drop it on a VPS.
Yeah, it's all, you know, more or less static.
So it's like, OK, you know, 500 people
brute forcing on at the same time
is not going to cause a problem or whatever.
Yeah.
So anyway, I'm back.
I'm back.
I do kind of like giving to I love giving talks
and the slide prep is not that bad anymore.
So I'm very pleased.
OK, I do have to give you a hard time, though.
Did I see something that said you signed some stickers?
OK, yes, I did.
Famous, Justin.
People are going to collect your sign stickers.
Listen, man, listen,
that was shout out to Everett, head of partnerships.
He's like, hey, man, I'm going to buy this.
This is a Sharpie
that we need to sign the stickers.
And actually, people really like that, though.
So after after the the talk,
you know, I they were like
we gave out a couple of signed stickers with with codes,
you know, to get free swag for CTPB on them.
And then people are coming up afterwards like, hey,
can you sign the sticker?
Can you sign the sticker?
And I'm like, OK, you know, and so I don't know.
That's cool.
No, I actually really like
I think Network Chuck for you and I both like wrote like
DC the day last year when he gave us
like Network Chuck stickers.
And that's like my favorite stickers on my laptop.
Yeah, I will say this kind of wearing off.
So we need another one.
Chuck, if you see this, but yeah, yeah.
The silver the silver Sharpie is the way to go.
Apparently, according to Everett.
So yeah, really great conference.
I'm I definitely going to go back next year.
I thought it was a blast
and the venue was really good.
Threat Locker killed it on how they put it on.
And so I'm going to go back and I really like that.
It has aspects of like there's definitely some more
like corporate cybersecurity stuff there.
But then there's also like literally
hands on the keyboard hacking stuff.
Yeah, operator labs as well.
Right.
So I think it's like a good like CISO and technical,
you know, conference, which I think is pretty rare.
It's one of the other typically.
That's dope.
Also, by the way, if you hear like hammering or tile cutting,
we have contractors upstairs.
So, dude, I also have contractors upstairs right now.
That's funny.
We're hopefully Richard.
Try your best with this episode, man.
Yeah, I'm going to try to mute between stuff, but we'll see.
Yeah.
All right.
We got a couple of things.
Yeah, not a lot of time.
So let's let's jump through it.
You're up first.
Okay, sweet.
I mean, a lot of a lot of this episode.
Don't don't let it scare you away.
I think it'll be really interesting.
You know, obviously, I've often been talking about hacking AI,
but this is going to be about using AI to hack.
Not the not the whole episode, but a lot of my content is.
And I'm doing that, honestly, because it feels like it's in the zeitgeist,
which if people don't know what that means, it's like that's
what's in the culture right now.
Like if you're on X, everyone's just like blowing up,
talking about using AI to hack and there's like overreactions
and there's bad takes and there's like good takes.
And so anyways, a bunch of the things I'm going to mention
are like relevant to that.
Our boy sweetly or sweet lie, however you want to pronounce it
updated BB scope.
He has like a website and like he updated the open source code.
So if you don't want to use the website,
you can just like spin up your own instance of it.
But I've always loved this.
I, you know, I'm kind of like a recon guy and love big fuzzing.
I've always loved BB scope to just like dump all this,
all of the scope for like, because, you know, there are things like,
is it a teaches like targets BB scope, something GitHub
that's like useful for all the public programs.
But if you want all of your privates, which is really, you know,
where often things are more likely to be found,
you can use BB scope to dump that and the like hacker one
a while back added like an API key.
So you're not using something sketchy
where you're like pasting in your cookies and all that.
And so anyways, he has a big new upgrade.
And I think you shared with me a link right before this,
which will drop it in the show notes that there was a pull request.
Like he released this like a couple of days ago.
And then as of like today, there's no pull request.
It allows you to actually just dump your reports,
which can be, which can be really useful.
Now there is some drama around that.
Also, if you want to get into that
about whether you should give your reports.
I don't know. I don't know.
I think I think it's good.
I think exactly what you did in what Corbin did as well,
where you just you dump your reports and you you say,
Claude, go build yourself a set of skills
to implement the techniques that are referenced in this report.
I think that is really, really good idea.
I haven't done it yet personally, but.
Well, well, Tommy's big pushback against that
is that we don't have the right to share it with third parties.
So Tommy was going at me on on X, our last guest,
which, by the way, if you haven't seen that episode, it's awesome.
Go check it out. But yeah.
You know, Tommy is obviously due to his past, a very,
a very by the book person these days, right?
Like he is very much by the book.
And I, you know, my personal belief is that if you've got, you know,
if you've set it in the settings for major model providers
that you trust, like Google OpenAi Anthropic,
that they can't train on your data,
I don't think there's any risk with like importing your reports
to cloud code or codex, whatever, to have it try to bypass
or to find adjacent bugs to that or to build skills.
If we get some if we get some sort of top down direction
that we shouldn't do that, then maybe it's a different discussion.
But anyways, that's the drama around that part.
Yeah, dude, I think it's I mean, I think that
we put these HGP requests into Kaido.
You know, we put these requests into Burp, you know, like there are
obviously it's different when it's going up to the cloud or whatever.
But like they're hosting stuff in AWS, right?
You know, a hacker one is right.
So there's third parties going to be involved in here.
Right.
And as long as there's some legal protection there around, like, you know,
they're not allowed to train on it.
And I just don't think that there's any chance
that they're going to be going through the, you know, tens of trillions
of tokens to go find like my report, you know, like it just seems silly.
Right.
Yeah, like get your head out of the freaking like I'm the main character vibe here.
Like no one gives a shit about your bug bounty reports.
Like it's exactly like if you've got some crazy like zero day on Android,
you know, then, okay, maybe you need to be careful, you know,
like like one of those $2.5 million chains.
If you have a Pegasus, if you have a Pegasus exploit, like maybe be careful.
Yeah.
But like really, if you're not in possession of something like that,
no one gives a shit, dude, like about you, you know, hey,
and I really, and I'm saying that as a higher profile individual,
like you're just shit about me.
Like it's, it's yeah.
Yeah, and I think what Alex said was really eye opening to it.
That we do actually retain full IP to our reports.
And so in some ways, I think we do have, you know, some types of rights.
I don't know exactly, you know, where all those boundaries are,
but I think that it is at the end of the day, still our IP.
It is oftentimes the company's IP also for their use, but it still is also ours.
So dude, I actually just logged into cloud.ai/setting/data
dash privacy dash controls and turned off those, those little.
Yeah.
Little things.
I haven't done that yet.
So I'm glad you reminded me to do that.
If you guys haven't done that, you could just log into cloud.ai,
go to your settings, go to the privacy tab and turn those off.
Yeah.
And maybe do that for each of your subs.
If you have multiple.
Exactly.
Who knows if you have multiple?
You, you certainly don't have multiple Joseph.
So yeah, I've never mentioned that.
No, I actually have three, three right now, but I'm hoping to keep scaling up.
So I feel like you're not allowed to say that, bro.
Okay.
Nevermind.
I don't have that many.
Ha ha ha.
Anthropic is like, I'm sorry, what'd you say?
Um, yeah.
So, all right, man.
Well, that's good.
Um, I actually, as our next topic, just wanted to give a shout out to, uh, our boy,
Matt Brown, who recently announced that he was going full time and, you know, pulled the trigger.
Long over job is a full time, um, you know, pen test content creator, bug bounty hunter, that sort of thing.
So if you guys haven't seen his channel, um, you're definitely going to want to go check it out.
We'll link it in the description.
He's n mat zero on, uh, Twitter.
And, um, yeah, his content is just the best content out there around for IOT device hacking, in my opinion.
Yeah.
And, and, you know, I think that this is very resilient and important.
Like, obviously I think for, for being resilient and bug bounty, I think that you can look at games,
look at desktop apps.
Uh, you know, there are things you can do to stay more resilient as like AI stuff kind of picks up.
But I think going into hardware hacking is one of the smartest plays you can do if you have the time
and the bandwidth to do it.
And his YouTube channel is gold.
Like it's just the best at hardware hacking, um, on YouTube.
And so, and he's one of the boys, you know, he's, you know, he's, he's been around the life hacking
event scene.
He's really cool.
Uh, we've got to support our support, our friends.
So, yeah.
And, and, uh, I will say one of the things he announced in his video was that he is also
doing training stuff by mass request.
Um, so he has two, uh, courses out there right now, digital signal analysis for hardware hackers
and beginner's guide to IOT and hardware hacking.
Um, and guys, these are grossly, grossly underpriced.
Uh, these are like $200 and $50.
Oh gosh.
Uh, so yeah, I got to hit up my boy and be like, what are you doing?
Yeah.
Uh, like, but yeah, definitely go check those out.
We're going to give away a couple of subscriptions, uh, to this critical thinkers tier on discord,
uh, as a way to support Matt, as he, uh, starts his endeavors here, but definitely a good place
to get started with, uh, for hardware hacking, if that's the route you want to go.
Yeah.
And if you have any hardware stuff or want any type of pen test, like he does contract
pen test.
So if you're a company, definitely reach out to Matt.
Yeah.
Um, all right.
What you got next?
Uh, the second thing is probably short.
So you might have me skip it, but original six sec on X, uh, I feel like, um, people have
maybe seen that before.
Are you going to share?
You may share.
No, no, go for it, man.
Oh man.
I'm logged in.
Um, anyways.
Oh, share your screen.
Yeah, it's fine.
I like to let you share where people can look it up themselves.
Anyways, I got you.
I got you.
Another bug bounty hunter who built a MCP style client for, um, accessing and listing
your reports and stuff.
Honestly, I was going to share this before sweetly upgraded his BB scope.
Um, I'd rather have it all in one tool, so I'll probably just use BB scope, but if
anybody wants to use like a MCP for hacker one to search your reports and that sort of
thing, that's a good one to do.
Okay.
Uh, yeah.
So my main thing, um, and this is like, actually I'm gonna let you go first.
I'll, I'll let that be my second small one.
Um, you go first because my, the rest of mine are all kind of around the same topic.
Um, okay.
So yeah.
And that'll be like a bigger discussion.
I got you.
So, um, the next item that I had to share on the list was I've just been having a lot
of success lately on Google with protobuf related stuff.
Okay.
And, and, and obviously there's like this proto Jason stuff that they're doing where, you
know, uh, they're removing the fields.
It's kind of like protobuf, but, but in Jason format, that is a necessity.
You've got to know how to deal with that.
If you're going to work hack on Google at all, that's not what I'm talking about.
What I'm talking about is the actual protobuf stuff.
Like there are a lot of parameters that are basically for encoded, like, you know, binary
protocol, protobuf stuff.
Um, and I think a lot of people just get scared of it and assume it's signed or, you
know, uh, just don't mess with it.
Um, and I've been messing with it and it's been given me some good stuff.
Uh, so I built a little Kaido, uh, convert workflow, which I'll drop in the discord.
Um, that allows you to just in line inside of Kaido, uh, decrypt those, uh, or I shouldn't
say decrypt, de-encode, decode those, um, uh, protobuf basic C4 encoded strings.
And then you can just kind of look at them.
They're not going to have the key, the key values, right?
That's the, the sad thing about protobuf is just, just has the value, but, um, you can
look at the value and kind of extrapolate what's going on there.
Uh, and so you'll see nested protobuf, so protobuf inside of protobuf and, uh, you
know, I'm not gonna lie, it does get to be a little bit of a pain, but if you, you know,
decode all of that stuff and you look deep into it, you'll find IDs, you'll find, you
know, strings that you, that you see get manifested in the UI, uh, and those things have
some really, really crazy impact once you start understanding it.
Yeah, it actually unlocks the ability to hack stuff that you kind of weren't able to like,
even like test before.
Yeah, absolutely.
And I did want to give just a really quick, um, explanation of how protobuf stuff works here.
Um, they've got, uh, a bunch of different, you know, features of protobuf, but one of the
things that I wanted to mention was that, uh, there, there are, you know, length delimited
strings, right?
So you can say, okay, I've got the string, it's this length and it's, you know, sort of
standard binary protocol like that.
But, um, they also encode the wire type, a field number and continuation flag inside of it.
Um, and that's kind of what the, you know, single eight bits recommend, uh, represents there.
So I'll, I'll explain very briefly, the first three bits are the wire type.
So this is like, oh, you've got a var int, you've got a string, you've got a, you know, a fixed
integer size, um, that's going to be encoded in those first three bits.
In the next four bits, you've got the actual field number that is associated with this content.
So if you have the protobuf, um, representation, you can map, you know, the key names back to the values.
Yeah, but if not, you're just going to get the field number that is associated with this
specific value, right?
Um, and that takes, uh, no, that's five.
Uh, no, that's five, five, four bits.
The last bit is, uh, the continuation bit, which allows you to continue expanding that metadata.
And then, um, you've got your actual data representation.
So it's a, it's a little bit complex, but once you kind of wrap your head around it, it's not too bad.
You got to familiarize yourself with the, um, different variable types and stuff like that.
Uh, and all of that gets extracted away by this kind of convert workflow that I use and just allows
me to say, okay, you know, field one maps to this string field two maps to this integer, that
sort of thing.
And if you just have even that rudimentary level understanding of it, then you can really
pop some cool bugs.
If you can reverse it, you know, write, take cloud code and say, Hey, re write me something
that reverses this.
Uh, and then you can inject into those various fields.
Does that, does that make sense?
Yeah.
Yeah, no, it makes sense.
And cloud is so good at it, man.
It, every time you handed a buffer, it's like, Oh yeah, of course the, the part of buff,
here's the Python script.
Uh, and I'm like, thank you.
Yeah.
And that wasn't true a year ago.
I actually wasn't.
Yeah.
So I've got a lot to say on that, but on the topic of Kaido and I'm wearing the Kaido shirt
today.
Um, and cloud code we released by, sorry.
We, me and Justin are advisors, but, uh, Kaido released a Kaido skill for cloud code or
codex or whatever to plug into it's at github.com/kaido/skills.
Um, and I'm like, Hey, I'm going to go ahead and do that.
And I'm going to go ahead and do that.
And I'm going to go ahead and do it.
I'm going to go ahead and do that.
And I'm going to go ahead and do that.
And I think having a sitemap coverage tree would be so cool.
Where it puts the sitemap into a plugin.
And then it marks them all red.
And then as you and Cloud Code add them to replay and test things,
it turns them all green.
And so you can be like, oh, I've definitively tested all this.
It makes me think of a long time ago.
I heard that Space Raccoon used to do that.
Especially when he first got started.
He would basically list out every API endpoint and every query.
And then all the bug class he likes to check for.
And he would have a coverage map in Google Sheets.
And he would just test every single thing.
And then you would end up finding a bunch of bugs that way.
Because he was way more thorough than anyone else.
Right?
That jerk, man.
You know, the same thing that Ron-Chan did.
That really like messed with me.
He's like, oh yeah, you need to be so thorough.
You need to like test every field.
And every value for every field.
Of every endpoint.
Of every mutation.
Of every freaking.
I'm like, dude, like stop.
You know?
And I don't know.
I'm still so jaded from this one live hack event.
Where I spent like an hour on this one, you know, trying to exploit this one endpoint.
And he popped in and got arbitrary ATO on like GitHub or something.
Or no, on GitLab.
Yeah.
And this is before he worked with them.
And it was because you missed like a single key, right?
Yeah.
And it's like, you know, it's like one of the weird, you know, values of the GraphQL schema.
Like doesn't look like it's going to do anything.
So you don't even really check it.
But then it like completely bypasses the whole off scheme.
It's like.
But yeah.
Dude.
On that exact same topic.
Cause it's like just relevant to all of this.
Cloud Code when hacking for me and XSS doctor basically found a high or maybe it's a critical on like a major company by looking at like the survey endpoints.
Like that's just the stuff that I always ignore, you know, like there's just stuff that's like feedback, submission, survey junk.
Same things with the same thing with those headers that there was like that big finding on last year, like trace headers or something.
It's like these things that like we get so used to as bug hunters used to ignoring that sometimes, you know, Claude or whatever we're using will end up testing.
So.
Dude, are you even hacking anymore, bro?
Are you just like directing Claude?
Like every time I hear you talking about it, you're just like directing Claude.
Yeah.
I feel like my job is more triage and validation like over the last six weeks.
It's crazy.
And I, and I mean, I don't think that it in any way, I mean, I'm sure over time it will degrade skills, but in general, I find that it's, it's like leveling up my heuristic for like where to look and what to look at.
And it's also, um, yeah, it's just finding stuff that I would, that I would have not found.
Right.
And so it's expanding my scope and my understanding of these applications, especially on big targets like Google, like just the random gadgets and information it finds about architecturally about these targets levels up my understanding architecturally where even if Claude code already go away, I now understand Google's infrastructure way better.
Yeah.
I think that is the plus.
I will say that I have found myself becoming a little bit lazy.
No, no.
Yeah.
Like the, the other day I, like a buddy of mine found a CSS injection and I was like, Oh yeah, dude, I'll just use like my stuff to hack this.
And I was like, Oh man, I'm going to have to like set up the font leak and the ligatures.
And, uh, all right, let me go do it.
And I started doing, I was like, Oh, I'll have Claude do it.
And then I spent like two hours trying to get Claude to do it.
And Claude couldn't do it.
No, you could have just done it.
No, I know.
I could have just done it myself.
And I'm like, no, I'm just going to like get Claude to do it.
And then it like, you know, and then you run it for the first five minutes and, and, and it's like, Oh wow, it's doing everything.
Like, this is going to be so fast and then something's off it, but you have no idea what, cause you didn't do any of it.
You know, and it's like, dang it.
Uh, so I don't know.
Sometimes you get big wins, but sometimes there's misses on that as well.
I think.
Yeah.
All right, dude, here's the major topic.
You got one more thing before I jump to this whole major topic.
Okay.
Yeah, I do.
Um, so I wanted to mention as well, and I, I mentioned this, I think briefly on the pod before, but I've actually been finding a lot of permissions issues, client side bugs recently.
And I wanted to mention a chain that is, uh, that is pretty good that maybe people can use.
So, um, one of the volumes I found recently was a sea surf of sorts to start recording with the victim's mic.
Uh, and then, you know, what would happen is if after a certain period of time, it would take whatever you said, transcribe it and put it into their service.
Right.
Okay.
And, and so I was like, okay, well, if I go to the site and I click allow, you know, allow this site to always access my microphone or whatever.
Um, then this doesn't require any user interaction at all.
You could, it can just start recording your microphone at any time.
Um, so what I did is I, I did a login sea surf to my own account.
Wow.
Then, then I, you know, audio record sea surfed, uh, the end point to start recording.
Sick.
And then after a certain period of time, it would, you know, cut the recording and, and then upload it to my account.
Right.
It's in your account.
Yeah.
I mean, it's in your account.
It's going to be on my account.
If it's on my account, I'm fine with it recording.
Right.
But if somebody log in C-Surf's their own account,
then I'm going to, you know,
now I'm just uploading data into somebody else's account.
You know, and it's like, oh, this is not good.
Well, I just love it because I think that taking a gadget like C-Surf,
like log in C-Surf and turning into something impactful is really cool.
Yeah, yeah.
So anyway, and then there's also the concept that I've talked about before
of like permission delegation down into iframes.
Like whenever you're seeing an iframe that you can control,
make sure you check the permissions, you know, the allow attribute on that
to like know whether it's allowing like screen recording, mic recording,
any of those things, and whether those permissions are being delegated
from the top-level frame down into the iframe.
And if it is, then you might be able to abuse those as a third-party iframe
inside of a trusted top-level page.
Right.
Yeah, I remember you'd mentioned that.
What's the name of that attribute again?
I think it's like the, I'm going to go pull it up right now,
but it's like the allow allow iframe permissions.
Yeah.
Pull it up on MDN.
The allow property.
Yeah, we've talked about the allow property of the HTML iframe element
indicates the permissions policy specified for this iframe.
So yeah, that's the one.
All right, dude.
So in a private discord that you and I are in, I've had lots of discussions.
I had these same discussions back whenever I was like getting a little bit better at coding
and it was like getting better at image gen and video gen.
You know, I was always like in there hyping it up as I, as I, as the hype man that I am.
But, um, I would get some pushback, you know, like, oh, I can definitely tell this is AI and that sort of thing.
And it eventually kind of pass, you know, of course you can still tell sometimes when things are AI, but it is getting harder.
But anyways, now that discussion has now kind of moved into over the last like week or two.
Can AI hack things, right?
And I'm sure if you're on X at all, you've probably seen all these discussions.
People are blowing up tweets like I found this with cloud code and I found that with cloud code.
And it's brought out, in my opinion, a couple different like, um, thoughts.
And these are, these are in my most recent blog post that I just put up on the, on the site.
Um, but the, the, the thoughts that, um, I often feel compelled to believe are things like even my grandma could do it.
Right.
Um, and there was some like really cheesy AI slop about my grandma finding a bug, you know,
not, not literally mine, but the person who was posting it.
Sorry for hitting my mic.
And, um, and I, you know, and I think that I am like, I tend to overestimate what other people can do, especially people who don't have our skill set for like our understanding for how we see bug bounty, how we see life, how we see coding, how we still see servers.
And in fact, you know, in building like small AI apps, um, for just like friends and family, when someone says, thank you, I'm like, ah, don't worry about it.
Claude did it.
And my wife's like, stop saying that.
Like, sure.
That's kind of true, but you know how to host the server.
You know how to tell it what to do, you know, like how it should build it.
And then when things don't work, you know how to fix it.
Like you're basically leveraging all of your technical expertise to like actually make this possible.
Right.
Okay.
I kind of disagree with that though, dude.
Like I totally, I agree with you, but like Claude can also do the hosting now.
Like you can literally just say like, host it, you know, and then it will go do that.
You know, I did that for the zero trust world thing.
Yeah.
But when you say it's going to say like, where do you mean to host it?
Right.
And so like for somebody who's non-technical, it's going to say like, okay, well, do you have a virtual server anywhere?
And when grandma says no, it's going to be like, okay, well you need to go sign up on this website.
Right.
And then get me an API key.
It's like, we know what API keys are.
We know how to sign up for websites.
We know.
And like that, that is a low barrier to entry.
But what I'm saying, what I'm trying to say here is I think that when I say, you know, kind of anyone can do it.
I'm talking about like anyone with knowledge of APIs and servers and who has done some hacking.
Right.
And at that point, I think I'm 1000% correct, but I don't think that like anyone can do it.
Okay.
Yes.
I agree.
But I think the difference between you and you and I who are like spending like time deploying stuff, hacking things, you know, very technical in the weeds.
Right.
And my friend Tobias, who is, you know, business IT automation, you know, is what he loves to do.
The, the gap between me and him just got a lot smaller.
A lot smaller.
Because, because he, he can now say to Claude, okay.
Yeah.
You need a VPS.
I got you.
You know, the, the IP address and I set the password to this login and then it just logs in and does it.
Right.
You know, he can do that.
Yeah.
You know, he can go grab an API key.
And, and, and, and you know, if you get given API key for digital ocean, it'll just get the domain.
It'll grab the thing.
You know, it can do all of that.
Right.
Um, so I don't know.
I, on, on one hand, certainly that's true, but, but I think the gap for between him and, and us just got a lot smaller.
And I also think it, it superpowers us, you know, to be able to do things like the gap between me and the person that invented Proto buff.
You know, like, you know, there's, there's tears to this.
And I think cloud helps, helps, you know, take people that have a general knowledge of something and be able to actually implement it, which is really beautiful.
Yeah, no, I agree.
And I think, and I think that for the, I think for anyone who is just like slightly further down, they can just keep asking like, okay, well, how do I do that?
Okay.
Well, how do I do that?
And when everybody's in that mindset, it really does, um, level everyone up.
But the other thing that kind of hit me was like, um, so let's say your, your buddy, your it buddy spins it.
He spins up a VPS.
He's using cloud code.
He's getting into bug bounty.
He's like, okay, go find these bugs.
Right.
So now what's the next limiting factor?
The next limiting factor is he doesn't know what is a false positive.
And so this is another thing.
This is another thing that actually Patrick pointed out to me and it's, you know, cause I'm kind of like, I kind of hate the fact that like any salesperson right now could just go use cloud code, make a hack bot and then go like rip a bunch of local businesses off, like running his hack bot as like a pen test service and selling pen tests.
Right.
But I think that the difference, um, and obviously business owners can't differentiate this, but the, the real difference between that and what I'm doing or what you're doing.
Or what you're doing is that we do know.
Right.
When, when it, when it, when it says jackpot critical finding, we're like, yeah, that's just a wild card course.
And it's not it's actually valid.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
And I do think, um, if you are building this and you're having those issues, the pro tip here is basically play whack-a-mole with those errors.
Right.
As you run it over the next week, go back and look at the false positives and incorporate those back into the prompt.
Like, Hey, when you found this, it was a false positive because of this.
When you found this, use those are critical on my rating.
That's more like a lower medium.
I still reported it, but like, you know, like basically play whack-a-mole with the issues it has and it will improve.
And so I think that that's, that's a good tip, but I do think that that's another place where our intelligence is baked in, um, to what we just expect of others, but that they might not be able to actually have or do.
Cause it often will even take me a while to fully grok and to fully validate some of these bugs.
Um, and it's because they're like weird ones.
Right.
It's like, it's not using my knowledge.
It has knowledge about stuff that I don't even understand.
Right.
And so then I have to go understand and figure that out.
Now we understand what it feels like to be a triage or, you know, where they're like, Oh, we just got this report.
Like I don't being a triage or I think is a really crazy skill.
You know, like you've got to be able to, you know, figure out the threat model, look at this person's attack vector that you've never heard of before.
Figure out if it's valid, you know, it's, it's pretty cool.
Um, but yeah, I, I don't know, man.
I think one of the areas I'm under using cloud right now is like getting more customization and playing whack-a-mole.
Like you said, like I'll often just really rely on like very few things that I have in my cloud MD file, a handful of skills, and then just spend most of the time actually just explaining to it.
Okay.
What to do.
Well, stop.
Let me fix that for you.
It's going to take like three lines.
Really?
It makes a big difference.
You just need to add to your cloud MD.
Anytime I get frustrated or anytime I have to re-explain something to you, to you that you did not understand, or anytime that you like try one command and it fails and you try another command and it fails and you try another command and it fails.
Add that to the applied learning section in your cloud MD.
And it will literally grow.
Like every time you use cloud, it improves.
It's like a self-improving loop that will then level up your own local cloud.
That will make it much better.
What?
Okay.
Are you mad you didn't do this?
Do you disagree?
What is it?
No, I just, I just like, I don't know, man.
I like, I don't really, I like, I feel like, is it going to know what things I want to have it improve on?
Like, I don't get frustrated with cloud.
I don't say like, listen here, you dummy.
You know, like I tell it, Hey, do this.
And I try to, you know, I don't know.
Okay.
Here's what, here's what I noticed when I'm using it.
I'll say, Hey, go pull up whatever that we were working on last week.
Go find it.
And what will it do?
It'll run like 20 different bash commands.
It'll try to find it in some places.
It'll try to use this thing.
It'll use too wide of a thing.
It'll find too many files.
It'll find too few.
Right.
Ever since I added that thing that I just told you now, what it does, like once it's like had to try something and got a bunch of errors or not found what it's looking for.
It will then update it.
It'll be like, you know, when Joseph asked me to look for session files in Claude, they're located in dot Claude slash sessions.
Right now, the next time I ask it to search, it only searches once.
And so it basically improves itself, which saves tokens and then like saves frustration, saves time.
Okay.
All right.
Fine.
I'll give it a shot.
All right.
Um, okay.
Before we, before we, we close though.
Um, one of the things I did want to discuss was, I think there's this whole concept of like token FOMO right now where people are like, I should be really, really utilizing my Claude Mac subscription to the absolute max.
I think you're doing a great job of that.
Um, they integrated Claude RC, which is something that I was really looking forward to with, um, like just being able to take your Claude session and, you know, resume it.
You know, resume it on your phone and give it instructions in the real time, but it doesn't support dangerously skip permissions, which is something that you essentially have to use if you're using Claude, because it's like, it's going to run 50 bash commands, you know, and you're like, I don't want to press.
Yes.
Every single time.
Like I want you to sit in this container that I've got you in and, and then do whatever the heck you want in my little container, you know?
Um, so I don't know, man, do you have any good solution to that?
I was kind of disappointed by RC.
Uh, I just haven't needed it.
I didn't need open call or RC and it's specifically because I just deployed a discord bot that creates a thread and in that thread, it's the same thing as a Claude session.
So I just have a private discord server.
I just, what do you just like about this look is good though.
Right?
Like, Oh, it looks great.
Let me see if I can take a good screenshot and share it with you all.
Um, want to do it very quickly, but basically put it in the doc or something because yeah.
Yeah, I'll put it in the doc, but basically what.
Redact it.
Yeah, that's fine.
What it looks like is, have you ever even seen?
This is a little pro tip for the listeners too.
Did you know that, uh, discord has a diff, um, code block type?
Ah, send me a message, send me a message to discord.
Actually, everyone listening along in discord do back, take back, take back, take diff and then have some lines with a plus and some lines with a minus.
The lines with a plus will be green.
The lines with a minus will be red.
Oh, interesting.
Wow.
What the heck?
That's cool.
It's beautiful.
And you can, so you just have it, write that out.
So I have mine, write out all the tool calls, all the things.
Let me see if I can, um, show you.
You don't have to redact in real time.
You can just put it in the doc and then we'll redact it afterwards.
And okay.
Yeah.
Well, let me, when I show you what this looks like, you're going to be like, Oh, I need that.
I'm going to put it in the doc and yeah, we'll just put it.
Yeah, that's true.
We can just like do overlay or I can even find a better picture.
Okay.
I just put it in the doc.
What do you think?
This is what, this is what my threads look like.
Yeah.
That looks pretty good, man.
You can see exactly what it's running.
And I even have it snip if it's too long.
And, um, and I, and I have it where I can like send audio messages in.
So what about control?
Oh, control.
Oh, oh, to show more.
Yeah.
I can't do control, but I do have things like, um, you know how you can control C if it's like going down a rabbit hole.
You just, you just send in like a stop command.
It stops it.
Um, okay.
Yeah.
And so you just had to code up this bot for you.
I had to code this bot.
I would maybe be willing to share it.
I'll think about that.
But either way, I mean, anyone.
There's plenty of solutions out there.
I'm sure.
And I will say you have to write custom handlers for like each tool call type.
So let me show you this in the doc.
Um, basically what I'm showing for the listeners only is that, you know how there's a to-do write and like a to-do read.
So I have mine use emojis for like the to-do, right?
So like right here, you can see it.
It's already finished all the to-dos at the top and it's working on the bottom one.
And so it updates that as it goes and it writes that out.
Um, wait, does it go back and update the message or does it write a new to-do list every time?
No, it's writing a new to-do list.
Yeah.
But it doesn't matter because I'm just watching the bottom anyways.
Right.
And at the, at the top of these, um, new threads, I have it give me the dash dash resume.
So if I need to go like jump on this on the VPS, I have a copy and pasteable command to jump straight into this session.
Hmm.
What are you so skeptical for?
This is great.
It's good.
I don't-
I can just hack from my phone basically like with continue.
Oh yeah.
Sorry.
I have that too.
So if I do slash my discord bot, um, resume, I can paste in the resume.
So this is basically like the RC continue or remote control.
Sure.
From my local machine or from my VPS.
And it will resume that session.
So then I can walk away and keep going.
Wait, do you have this running on your local machine and on your VPS?
Um, no, the bot doesn't actually have access to local.
Okay.
Just got it.
You could do the same thing if you wanted to, but it would have to pick it up from local or SCP it or something.
Yeah.
All right, man.
I don't know.
I just like, I, it's not good.
The cloud interface, the cloud code interface on the phone is not good.
It's not good.
It's bad, but it looks like how I want it to look.
Yeah.
You know, like it feels how I want it to feel, but like the implementation is really bad.
Here's the, here's the best by the way, since we're about to end.
Um, yeah.
Here's like a, the type of diffs it writes whenever it's updating stuff for me.
Oh, wow.
Dang.
That's super gorgeous.
I know it's actually, it's actually easier on the eyes than the, than the T UI.
Dang.
Okay.
All right.
Maybe that, that one I'll give you a maybe on.
I will definitely go add to my cloud, cloud MD file, you know, the self-improvement loop
thing.
But, uh, well, here's the thing about the discord bot.
You don't have to use it.
Like what it's really useful for is a lot of times on my VPS.
Like, let's say I'm out and about and you know, somebody messages me as like, Hey,
here's this critical thing.
Can you validate it real quick?
I will then just like pull up my phone, pull up discord, do like start a new session in that
new thread and just be like, Hey, validate this for me.
Or I'll say like, Hey, you know, my, my website went down.
Can you check out, like check the logs real quick, check the errors.
It's kind of like my dev ops engineer on speed dial in discord where I'm already at anyways,
when I'm out and about when I don't have my computer.
And so I can both hack from remote or check on things via remote or download things.
Or I can say like host this from my friend at this path.
And I can do all of that without my computer.
Yeah.
But like, can you do that?
Like, does it take images?
Does it take voice recording and stuff like that?
Cause even with Claude bot, I had issues with that back in the day.
Yeah.
No, all the day being like three weeks ago when Claude bot got popular.
No, mine, mine does accept attachments and it does accept voice.
I don't have it accepting images, but I mean, it would be mostly trivial, trivial to use.
I just never have to give it images.
So yeah, that makes sense.
All right, man.
We'll see.
We'll give it a shot.
I feel like this episode was like a bunch of us talking about Claude, but the world is
really changing man with the way that it works with, with bug mounting stuff right now.
I think, yeah, actually let me respond to that with like, even though we're going over by
like one minute here, I do have to go pick up my daughter, but I, I think that people who
are annoyed by us talking about AI or AI hacking, like they're just like, they are just, they
did, they're just missing out or they're just being, um, like grumpy about it.
Because like, even if, even if you're only going to use it to just write code for you to like reproduce
something, or even if you're only going to use it to host a POC.
Like you're silly to not, to not use it for some things like that.
Right.
Or even if you're only going to use it for reversing RPC.
Like let's, you don't have to use it as your full blown hackbot.
If you don't want to like, I know bus factor, he like just really wants to be human in the loop with it.
Right.
But it found him a high on a program that pays 8k for highs last night.
And before that he was kind of like skeptical.
I didn't really like it.
It was kind of just like piecing it together or copying and pasting from chatbots.
And now I think he's probably going to be hooked because that one bug will pay for his usage for three years.
Right.
And, um, and there's no doubt it's going to get better.
So that's one thing I didn't get to mention was, you know, I think the reason why this is so possible,
like hackbots worked a year ago, right?
Expo or whatever, like companies were able to do some stuff with it, but you had to have a bunch of
like specialized, uh, rappers, specialized prompts.
And I, the reason for that was because the models were not that smart.
You needed the internal monologue of experts or good reports in the context.
You don't need that anymore because Claude Opus 4.6, even Sonnet 4.6.
And I think Douglas Day has been using Haiku and finding bugs with it.
He's found like five figures worth of bugs, like in the last couple of weeks.
And he's using like mostly Haiku is because they went in cyber bench from like 30% to like 69% of pass rate.
What this means is the models actually understand hacking better than they ever have before on this most recent release.
And so anyways, people can be skeptical.
People can be mad.
I don't really care.
I think that this is going to continue to impact our industry.
And it, you have the opportunity to really like level up and make more money this year or more, more bugs.
Um, and people should do it.
So yeah.
Yeah.
Well, GG, man.
I think that's true.
And I think, you know, just a moment ago, I, I sort of had that experience with, with shift a while back, you know, and I got that 15 K bounty.
And every time I just recently had to go and, uh, refill my open router with credit credits.
I was like, oh man, do I put another 200 bucks on here?
And I'm like, wait a second.
This is already paid for itself time and time and time and time again, you know?
So yeah, it's definitely worth it.
All right.
Let's, let's make, let's, uh, let's call it a wrap then.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Yep.
Peace.
And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking.
Thanks so much for watching to the end y'all.
If you want more critical thinking content, uh, or if you want to support the show, head over to ctbb.show/discord.
You can hop in the community.
There's lots of great high level hacking discussion happening there on top of the masterclasses, hack alongs, exclusive content, and a full-time hunters guild.
If you're a full-time hunter, it's a great time.
Trust me.
I'll see you there.
Bye.